what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are covering dark days the
casting as part of our lead up to dark
nights metal now for those of you guys
who want to get caught up those of you
guys who feel a little left out or
you're trying to figure out everything
that's going on if you're new here to my
channel you will find down in the
description a playlist that will have
most everything you need to be able to
understand everything that's going on
right now with regards to dark days and
dark nights metal and all that kind of
good stuff and also post that playlist
at the top of the the front of my
youtube channel so you guys shouldn't
have a hard time finding it but the
story to Casting is huge and here's the
crazy thing reading this story I felt a
lot like Alice in Wonderland tumbling
down the rabbit hole and that's what the
story feels like to me because if you
understand what you're looking for or if
you've been reading DC for a pretty good
amount of time
there are a lot of Easter eggs in this
story dark days the casting none more so
than what we get right off to that
remember in our video on the fours we
had talked about how the forged story
basically just introduced the notion of
instumental or at least is expanded on
it if the metal had been around for a
long time but it was never really
anything DC had delved into they never
really offered an explanation on it it
was just a metal that exists out there
and it was as ambiguous as it was
obscure in the realm of DC Comics and so
the result is that dark days the forge
began to expand on this and it started
following the story of a guy named
Carter Hall but Carter Hall was the
original Hawkman all the way back in the
day you know way back when the character
first showed up and over the course of
DC's publication history his stories
waxed and waned but the idea is that
Hawkman basically is reborn in a new
body every time he dies and so because
of that what the forge did is it came
back and it introduced the idea that
Carter Hall had basically been
introduced to in metal this base is
behind the various powers that he has
and what he's capable of doing but it
also sent him tumbling down this rabbit
hole of trying to figure out what in
metal was why it was powerful why aliens
had crash-landed on his own body on
their home planet introducing in metal
in the first place and so what this does
is it basically creates a gathering of
source now this happens near the dawn of
the 20th century and something that I
hope you notice here is that the
descriptions that we get identify with
the individuals who are here for example
the rhyming dress the running demon of
Camelot that's Etrigan from the just the
DC you know sorceries and all that kind
of stuff the brothers who keep secrets
and mysteries
that's Cain and Abel and that's huge
because
can enable our part of the religious
pantheon they're part of bertigo
you know when it comes to things like a
man as old as America that's Uncle Sam
he's a character that hasn't appeared at
least not that I'm aware of since before
the new 52 since just after you know
Infinite Crisis and so on the sorcerer
of zeal ishani Nights the cavemen that's
a reference to the immortal man in
Vandal Savage
phantom strangers this is basically a
veritable who's who of individuals who
have been brought together by Carter
Hall and the reason for this is because
of the fact the Carter halls trying to
get an answer to the question what is
nth metal and why is it so powerful we
also end up seeing things like the
dagger of Shazam well actually see that
you know a little more here than here in
a bit once we get into that discussion
but the other half of this is that where
the whole aspect of Carter Hall trying
to track down then the basis and the
nature of intha metal takes place in the
distant past or in the relatively
distant past in the present moment right
now in DC Comics Batman is trying to
figure out what's going on with within
metal and the cool thing about this is
that we had seen things in the Forge
like the return of the anti-monitor
Tower basically that we saw during
Infinite Crisis we don't know where it
came from we don't know how Batman got
it it's just there and it was one of
those huge reveals from from dark days
the forge that was never really expanded
on presumably it'll be expanded on
during the actual Dark Knights metal
storyline but for right now we have no
answers to that question but in his
pursuit to figure out what's going on he
ends up catching up with Wonder Woman
now something to keep in mind here is
that Wonder Woman makes reference to the
idea that the gods have long since
abandoned earth because a war is coming
and that was covered in Greg Rucka as
Wonder Woman the idea that she's never
been back to to thin the spirit and all
the times that Wonder Woman had left a
mascara and all the times that she had
gone back to this and she was never
going there you know she was basically
in her own mind she was retreating into
her own head it was really the biggest
reveal of the Greg Rucka run essentially
saying that she's been in the DC
Universe the entire time and was never
able to go home but one of the things
about the idea with regards to these
gods effectively abandoning humanity
comes in the form of her you know
presenting Batman with the last of the
great weapons of the gods which is
basically a sort of Apollo what you know
is essentially just this weapon that's
called the Sun blade and it's wildly
powerful in terms of what it can do but
we won't actually see it put to any good
use instead we transition over to the
Joker now remember in dark days the
forge the tale land of that story the
very you know last page revealed was the
idea that the Joker was still alive but
remember following the events of
Darkseid war there's three jokers out
there and we don't know which one this
is but it's one down and two to go and
so because of that we know this is the
Joker from like in game and from death
of the family and so on and so forth but
a lot of people were asking the question
when I was going through those early new
52 runs which again you'll find that
playlist that we have down in the
description a lot of people were asking
question how did the Joker come back if
the Joker was basically dead as the
Joker had been killed off how did he
return the great thing about this is
that the Joker gives us this answer as
part of you know Scott Snyder's new 52
Batman run with the court of owls and
different things like that he introduced
a substance called Dionysian and
Dionysian was basically this liquid more
or less that allowed people to tap into
it and in turn either experience
immortality or at the very least to
prolong their lives but how long their
longevity lasted dependent on how cure
the Dionysian was for someone like
Vandal Savage
he had basically tasted of the Dionysian
in its most pure form for someone like
the Joker it's diluted it's just kind of
eroded over the ages or something along
those lines but the result is that the
Joker is not truly immortal instead the
Dionysian serve the purpose of basically
engulfing the Joker's body and
effectively healing him allowing him to
return now the other half of this is
also the character of Duke Thomas and
that's one of the big things that Scott
Snyder's really just coming kind of you
know keeping on the back burner the
entire time in all-star Batman
Duke Thomas was a character who appeared
all the way back during the events of
endgame but in game was basically the
story was Duke Thomas's parents being
forced to succumb to the exact same
thing as Bruce Wayne's parents in the
sense that the Joker basically took Duke
Thomas and he kidnapped him and he took
his parents and he was going to have his
parents killed by Joe Chill the same
person who killed Batman's parents but
the question was why Duke Thomas why is
Duke Thomas so special well the Joker
ends up answering that question here in
a little bit what we end up doing what
we end up doing at the moment is we
actually transition back over to Carter
Hall and again this is just kind of an
investigation it's kind of poking around
looking at all these different things to
go on with regards to you know this
investigation trying to understand how
it all works and of course using
technology to his advantage and
essentially opening this dimensional
rift of sore
and peering in all these fees on the
other side is just darkness death a
hunger a desire to destroy all things
and that's what's kind of cool about
this was because it's got Snyder drawing
on the nature of when you stare at the
abyss the abyss stares back then we end
up seeing characters who were brought in
like public when Batman transitions back
over to the Sonoran Desert in Arizona he
ends up running into double X well as
far as I'm aware we haven't seen duplex
for quite some time but he was
originally a character I believe that
was introduced in the 1970s by Jack
Kirby and he was just part of project
Cadmus which at the time and really you
know sort of continues to be this sort
of scientific arm in the realm of DC
Comics but double X was basically a guy
who was cloned
using metahuman powers an incredible
telepath in your illusion caster but the
fact remains you know where he's
effectively overcome by his inability to
keep these illusions up ultimately once
he collapses we're basically revealed to
Talia al Ghul
now why Talia al Ghul is here we're not
really given an in-depth explanation all
we're told is that somewhere along the
line Ra's al Ghul had access to an
extremely powerful weapon and he's been
trying to get it back ever since and the
implication here is that the weapon that
Ra's al Ghul had at one point is in fact
this Sun blade but it's not explicitly
stated it's just a weapon that existed
somewhere along the line and so what
happens is that because this Sun blade
is made of eight metal which seems to be
a metal it's maybe weaker than in metal
the higher the number the more durable
the material we're not really told
explicitly but a trade is basically
offered here in that sense that Batman
offers up the Sun blade and response for
the dagger of Shazam now this brings him
to the end of question
where is Shazam what is he doing I keep
seeing this question all the time in the
comments everybody's asking Robb were
Shazam tell us where she's damaged It
was as if I somehow have secret super
inside information on the comic book
industry but Shazam has only appeared
one time in DC rebirth and that was for
a couple pages and Hellblazer rebirth in
the first volume and it's when John
Constantine basically returns back to
back to New York all hell breaks loose
wonder woman asks Shazam should we get
involved and ultimately it's no we'll
just wait and we'll see what happens if
things pop off we'll get involved if not
what does let Constantine do his own
thing and that's
last time that we see him now the
important thing to keep in mind is it
Jeff John's a guy who is basically
spearheading the whole DC rebirth thing
I did an interview during San Diego
comic-con 2016 I think it was and he was
asked the same question where is Shazam
and the statement that he made is that
Shazam will have a huge role to play
especially when it comes to the events
of The Watchmen getting involved in the
DC Universe least I'm pretty sure that's
what he said so his name's not being
written out he's not being ignored he's
not being thrown on the back burner
never to be seen or heard from again
he's basically being held because he's
going to have an extremely important
role later on but the idea is that you
know the Joker effectively you know
transitioning back to Duke and Green
Lantern the Joker starts tearing up this
machine that Batman had built but we
didn't really know why all we knew is
that this machine was basically created
during the events of super heavy which
was a Batman story arc that was done as
part of Scott Scott Snyder's final run
the last little tidbits that he did
before the whole events of DC rebirths
kind of setting off but all we really
knew about this machine was it was
designed for the purpose to guarantee
that there would always be a Batman but
that may would be able to essentially
come back if he ever were to die now the
other half of this is that the Joker is
not playing the role of a bad guy here
he's not playing the role of a villain
and that's why this is so big because
remember the Green Lantern Hal Jordan is
not here of his own volition he's not
here because he was stumbling across
Gotham City one day and said I wonder
what Batman is doing he was sent here by
the guardians of the universe and so
what this means is that whatever it is
is going on in this Batcave whatever it
is that Batman's doing is big enough to
draw the attention of the guardians of
the universe which is a pretty huge deal
now once you know Green Lantern has
effectively taken out or at least
knocked out temporarily by the Joker the
Joker immediately turns his attention to
Duke Thomas and that's when we basically
get this entire revamp of the concept of
metahuman in the world of DC Comics
because for years and years and years
and years metahumans are basically
evolved or arrived in DC Comics through
one of two means either it was genetic
or the powers were bestowed upon them
and that's a universal constant in the
realm of comics either people are born
with powers or powers are given to them
with regards to the Joker in terms of
how he relates to Duke Thomas what he
basically says is this in the early days
you know back at a point where
technology wasn't nearly as advanced as
it is right now there wasn't the ability
to easily say this person is a metahuman
that person is a metahuman
it was a very primitive system it was
very primitive basis the idea behind
this was that when a person was
basically born there would be a test
that would be done on them but the only
way to verify this was to send up a flag
to basically say yes this person has
powers this person doesn't but they were
only given four letters that they could
possibly use and so instead of you know
saying super powers you know crazy
abilities to telepath telekinesis or
whatever the four letters were in the
ETA meta however that's not what they
were testing for they were not testing
for powers specifically they were
testing for the basis behind powers what
was being scanned for was metal
they were scanning for a particular
substance in the blood of the person who
was born if that person had this metal
in their veins they would just put up a
flag that says meta which is short for
metal and so what this does or at least
what this means is DC's essentially
coming back and saying that the term
meta human derived from the fact that
these individuals who were born with
powers had this int metal in their blood
and the result is that when they were
born this flag was set up to indicate
that what it seems to be happening here
is that anybody who's born of the earth
anybody who is not Superman or Wonder
Woman or something along those lines
basically gains their abilities because
they have int metal in their blood now
what does also does is it introduces the
notion of why people are able to gain
powers take for example somebody like a
flash Barry Allen the flash Barry Allen
was not born with powers he was not born
with the ability to move extremely fast
but the question was always asked how is
it that very Allen was dousing chemicals
as struck by lightning and not melted
into sludge after it all happened the
answer this being given here is in metal
he had in metal in his veins and so
because of that instead of killing him
it gave him powers now how this is going
to play out we don't truly know but what
this does mean is it offers an
explanation as to why people have
abilities in the realm of DC Comics what
this also does is it presents the notion
that if somebody can figure out a way to
tap into that whole thing they can in
turn give people powers and so that
creates some pretty interesting
scenarios because what happens if the
watch that are fighting to Justice
League and war Shaq is somehow managed
to return from the dead and has a grudge
against dr. Manhattan well here comes
Batman injecting war Shaq with the
powers of Superman and suddenly you've
got war Shaq fighting document Hatton
and so again there's all kinds of
different things that can come out of
this and all kinds of different
scenarios that could unfold here and so
ultimately what we end up having in the
middle of this whole thing where the
Joker is able to you know temporarily
subdue Duke Duke Thomas only for you
know Hal Jordan to basically emerge here
and to reveal hey look I'm a pilot you
literally threw me into the hangar a
Batman you know more or less bring the
Joker down what's also being done here
is it's revealing the fact that Jude
Thomas himself is a metahuman Duke
Thomas has powers and that's why the
Joker chose him The Joker started doing
some investigation he got it started
doing some poking around it tells us
what the Joker was doing between the
events of Batman death of the family and
Batman in game that instead of just
sitting around and trying to figure out
a way to poison the Justice League with
Joker toxin that he was doing his
homework he was studying everything that
was going on behind the scenes and what
he ended up coming to the realization of
was that if Batman were able to
basically use this machine and was able
to tap into some other dimension or
something along those lines he would
bring ruin to everything and so in this
story The Joker is the good guy that's
the craziest thing about this the Joker
is the hero in the story because he's
trying to stop that man from engaging in
universal calamity now the other thing
to keep in mind here is that Batman
doesn't realize what it is that he's
doing he's not aware of the fact that
he's engaging in universal calamity and
Batman's perspective he's trying to
figure out what in the world is going on
here and so ultimately what ends up
happening is we basically have Duke
Thomas manifesting his powers and
essentially being given a name this
signal and so what seems to be going on
with regards to Duke if he can
essentially take something that
previously existed and then in turn show
what it used to look like the
implication here is that he can see how
things are supposed to work and so of
course with Hal Jordan giving him a
Lantern ring in turn he's able to
basically conjure a construct that
represents or looks exactly the way the
Machine used to look and so what this
does is it'll it allows that man to
basically get this machine together and
start functioning and start using it and
in turn curing into this
interdimensional portal now of course
the responsive is is that there's
nothing there all he saw was darkness
and the cool thing about this is that we
end up finding out at the end of the
story that this darkness that Batman
sees was designed to be that way that
there are these individuals whom we know
nothing about and that we've never seen
before who reside
3,000 miles below Gotham City who are
basically under this pit of Dionysian
far below the Batcave and the
implication here is that they basically
force Batman to see darkness he didn't
actually see dent he didn't see what was
going on and so what seems to have
happened is that Batman peering into the
darkness basically saw all these
different versions of himself who were
inherently evil and this father of all
Batman which is to say the Batman that
seems to have come before or something
along those lines ultimately Batman was
kept from seeing that but that's what
awaited him on the other side and so
that's what Dark Knight metal seems to
be it's all these invasions you know of
all these evil alternatives to Batman
himself and so again it's gonna be crazy
it's going to be absolutely bonkers but
if you guys are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob Court
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and also make sure you
check that description down there that
will have all the videos that you need
to understand what's going on with Dark
Knight's metal something else that I
want to point out here is that there is
pre lose to Dark Knights metal outside
of this there's like Teen Titans number
12 different things like that those
entire story arcs will just be thrown in
there just because of the fact that I
did full stories instead of like single
issues or something along those lines so
you'll find all that stuff down there
and I should be able to help you guys
sort through everything and you know go
through in chronological order in order
to get prepped for darts night dark
nights no but anyway guys we're going to
go ahead and bring this video to an end
and I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you